it's time for drew's news your news
seashell hold it up to your ear for the
soothing good sounds of news
and with me at the desk is my little
puka shell rossi ross matthews
yeah hi everybody hi
don't let them too close to me
i sound like the ocean if you hold me up
to your ear drew well isn't that
pleasant yeah well let's see
[Laughter]
well um you have uh the first story
today which is actually going to
matriculate into something else well you
know we do the news here every single
day and this season we have desk we will
travel and today we're going back to
hollywood drew that's right um danny
pellegrino the host of the everything
iconic podcast joined us this podcast is
huge it's like one of the biggest uh
like millions and millions and millions
of listeners bajillions oh really i'm
not a mathematician but good to know
neither am i
um which is why i say no rules um
but he really is uh everyone kind of
shows up and does his show it's a big
deal that he came and hung out with us
and he delivers
love letters to pop culture every single
week and together we tackled um
actually we we're doing a few segments
with him and a lot of them are based in
films that i was a part of and sort of
like spilling the tea yeah because he's
really good he's a journalist he gets
down to it so he he gets the stuff
you've never heard about her biggest
movies um he got some stuff out of me
that i actually felt really vulnerable
about really yes
he i'm like gosh as a budding journalist
now myself
um i'm like how does he do it because he
he caught me off guard several times i
could tell really yes i could totally
tell because i'm so good on the fly
and he was i was like uh-huh uh-huh well
let me see now okay um yeah you know
and i'm a terrible liar and like the
worst actor ever i know that sounds so
stupid
but i can't lie
so he got me in some really
uncomfortable positions
um and uh
um this one's about the film charlie's
angels take a look
it's danny bellerina
hello i'm so honored so excited to be
here with a true icon two of you thank
you so much for having me it's ironic
that you have a podcast called
everything iconic because you yourself
have become very iconic do you see the
iconic irony i do not but i will take
that and i will uh yes thank you i will
take that in today we're going to
revisit a movie that is near and dear to
my heart hollywood insider reports that
charlie's angels
is now available to stream on netflix
for the first time
a classic movie drew you know i couldn't
come here without talking about
charlie's angels i'm so excited to dive
in it opened at number one at the box
office in november of 2000
uh it's a fantastic movie and i want to
go back to the first movie where it all
started
let's check out this incredible fight
scene from charlie's angels
[Applause]
that is so crazy to see what is it like
to look back at that
well um we trained so hard you know um
uh crouching tiger hidden dragon and the
matrix were sort of just the biggest
trending sort of phenomenons in action
movies so we were lucky enough to work
with the team that did both of those
movies and it jump started female lead
action movies of that sort of era and i
didn't want to do an action movie that
was like i'm so dark and cool and a
badass and i'm going to do this and that
i was like i want to be like this and
then surprise you with the capabilities
when we talk about people you share the
screen with and charlie's angel of
course you share with cameron and lucy
there were always these rumors about a
part of three and a part four starring
you guys how close were we to getting a
part three with all of you guys what was
it gonna be about like can you tell me
all of it
i think
to be really honest
we all got to be in each other's lives
all the time and we were such good
friends that we were so satisfied we
didn't feel like we needed to make a
movie in order to be together anymore
because we were together i gotta say
lucy is out there you know right now
talking about her instance with bill
murray
and um i did this whole video and like
sent it to her to back her up and she
was like nah i don't need it what
happened exactly you want to know what
happened
you want to spill the tea yes um okay so
what really happened was bill was just
in a you know comedians can be a little
dark sometimes um and he just came in in
a bad mood and what you have to know
is how much lucy stood up for herself
and
that was
the
great thing that came out of an
unfortunate circumstance
she literally said i do not accept that
kind of behavior from you
and we all supported her and backed her
up and we moved forward was it all
directed at her or was it just a general
there was a general and then he zeroed
in on her
and um
in the workplace it is so important that
we respect each other and if you don't
feel you're being respected to speak up
for yourself and to have people around
you say i back this person i love that
but i respected her then i respect her
now
i'm proud of us as a team and a company
that we didn't tip toe on the eggshells
we dealt with it right then and there
we were strong and we moved forward and
we didn't accept anything less moving
forward
yes i love that lucy said that you know
she was an action hero in the movie i
feel like she was a superhero in real
life she really was yeah she really was
i mean charlie's angels i can't stress
enough just how great it was and how
iconic for the time it was and i always
hoped that the three of you would get
together and it was so wonderful to see
the three of you on the talk show but i
still think we are holding out hope for
some sort of reunion
scripted or something can we just hold
out hope that maybe one day there could
be a third one could be please i i will
always hold out hope okay um because it
is something that is so personal to me
you know that was a four-year five-year
endeavor as a producer
do you guys want a third one i would go
yes hello
if you ever do we will all show up and
be there it probably may be like more in
the golden girls era okay
that sounds even better charlie's angels
we've all moved to miami and charlie's
angels on the lanai yeah exactly
thank you rossie and thank you the
phenomenal danny pellegrino and to get
more from danny on the spectacular
podcast you can go to everything iconic
right now
[Music]
you